[Music]
now another superstar that will be
hitting the stage during of the weekend
is Jennifer Lopez she will be performing
at DirecTV nouns Super Saturday night
concert but last night JLo was in LA
with her main man Alex Rodriguez JLo hit
the guest red carpet solo at 8:45 last
night and minutes later was joined by
her boyfriend of almost a year Alex
Rodriguez the couple went glam for their
date night JLo with her hair up in curls
and Alex in a blue velvet jacket it was
all to celebrate JLo starring role in
Guess's spring ad campaign the couple
even posed in front of J Lo's print ads
despite all the excitement and glamour
the party's timing couldn't have been
worse just hours before the event got
underway former guest model Kate Upton
claimed on social media that the
company's co-founder Paul Marciano quote
sexually and emotionally harassed women
Kate also posted quote it's
disappointing that such an iconic
women's brand is still empowering Paul
Marciano as their creative director
hashtag me to Marciano reportedly said
he won't apologize because he's done
nothing wrong
and this afternoon JLo released the
statement that read in part quote any
accusation should be fully and
thoroughly investigated meanwhile the
four judge and Republic Records exact
Charlie walk is out of the Fox music
competition show walk has been accused
of sexual harassment when he worked at
Sony records
Charlie denies the allegations it will
not attend the four finale next week
quote I do not want my presence to be a
distraction
[Music]
you